what's going on guys it is season
premiere week all of the fall TV shows
are coming back including so many of our
favorite superhero TV shows we're living
in a renaissance of superhero shows
there is great incarnations there's
interesting incarnations and there's
everything in between we're gonna talk
about those today with an esteemed panel
let's meet him first
he's an old friend of screen junkies
he's the host of DC all-access Jason
Inman he's a friend of the show he's
been here several times now and he is
the critic at large for the Nerdist Kyle
Anderson this young man is an actor and
he's a performer at the UCB theater and
a nerd of the highest caliber
Jason Wain Christian we have a
professional in the comic industry yeah
we have a critic and we have someone
who's a real fan everyday guy yeah guys
before we get started I'd like to tell
you that today's episode is sponsored by
RetailMeNot the best way to get
thousands of coupons right at your
fingertips on your phone with
RetailMeNot you can get up to 60% off at
great stores like Target and Best Buy
and some exclusive deals go ahead and
text screen junkies 242 767 or click the
link on the screen to get the free
RetailMeNot app now so guys to kind of
give this conversation some parameters
let's lay out the shows that were mainly
going to talk about today arrow the
flash daredevil Gotham and agents of
shield let's start things off with
what's one thing that's kind of
disappointed us the thing that stands
out the most to me about all these TV
shows is agents of shield agent shield
was introduced as the show that was set
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe how
much of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
have we seen in that show barely
anything because they're so tied to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as soon as
Captain America - did what it had to do
then they change the show completely and
then in this season the second season it
changed completely to something else it
has no consistency Gotham I don't even
want to call a disappointment because of
how terrible it is so I would rather say
I'm more disappointed with arrow or how
they've handled the third season now
that they're trying to get all their
movies going and they have Suicide Squad
coming up
really being protective of markets that
they think they're going to be able to
do films about but I feel like they've
already decided to diverge the two
universes because they've already cast a
flash for the film University Miller
versus Grant Gustin
right probably one of Superman on arrow
or flash they probably want to Batman
but besides that I feel like they can do
whatever the tone of arrow does it get
to soap opera at times in the first
season we watched it to drink and make
fun of it we watched it because it was
awful and he was just a murderer but
every episode they would fix the
problems that they had not just by
ragging it but within the context of the
show and it got better and better and
better and better and then I was uh
Nayana CLE just a huge fan and one of
the coolest things that arrow does is it
has so many comic-book Easter eggs this
season on arrow
he used the boxing glove arrow that is
like a fan dream to see that in
live-action it pays homage and
celebrates the comic book I feel like
that's one thing we lost an agents of
shield would we have enjoyed agents of
shield much better if it starred Nick
Fury Samuel Jackson was a regular cast
matter and it was Nick Fury agents of
shield it was if it was the same writing
I think it would have had the same
problems there just would have been a
lot more sass and action in it one thing
that was fun though is they still got a
lot of the Easter eggs and agents have
shield as well not to the same extent
that the DC television series do and I
think that's something that again the
Gotham lacks they ignore all of the fun
of comics yeah so let's talk a little
bit about Gotham I know there's so much
disappointment surrounding the show so
what happened I feel like they did they
didn't stick to the premise that they
put forth people don't care about Gotham
without the villains so they're bringing
the villains in and making it like the
villains or what creates Batman as
opposed to the other way around which is
I guess fine but that's not the
direction that they set out initially
but so now it just seems like who else
can we have in here like you know
they've had the Scarecrow already
they've had someone who may or may not
be the Joker and you know the penguin
and Edward nygma starting to go and say
I was fine what the penguin makes
perfect sense and all the old crime but
like I can't help but assume it was
based or at least inspired by Gotham
central which is an incredible Brubaker
book it takes a look at the
Gotham Police Department during Batman's
time to me that's a much more
interesting premise that you still don't
need Batman to show up at all I think
Gotham could become such a better show
if it leaned away from the Batman and
focused on Gordon because Jim Gordon's
storyline is a story that we've only
seen a couple of times yeah and we've
seen Batman's storyline it was called
Batman's Begins
just have him go off and train with
ninjas and let us see Gordon's story Jim
Gordon was my favorite character in
Batman year one yeah he's a compelling
like kick-ass dude I feel like with with
arrow and flash the the writers love
their material and they know their
material inside now with agents of
shield the writers know their material
and are incredibly well researched and
meticulous and with Gotham the writers
heard about Batman once from someone
drunk in a bar well that about sums it
up thanks for watching yeah well-put
well put with that in mind the key to
agents of shield is maybe a little less
procedural and the key to Gotham a
little more procedural and and a little
bit more passion from the writers in
both projects but yeah and that energy
and love is something that we see in the
superhero show that we haven't talked
about yet which is the best approach
show on television the flash yeah that
show introduced time travel versus a
multiverse and a talking gorilla it was
all cool seeing a realize and satisfying
Gorilla Grodd right pretty cool and I
think that the most amazing thing about
that show is that they allowed
themselves to have fun with the format
and because the flash is a fun character
it's the only one of these shows that
we're talking about today that's
actually kind of fun and upbeat yeah I
mean I love daredevil daredevil not fun
not fun yeah not a fun show yeah it it
gives a you know great service to the
comics what else do we like about as far
as the writing and the way the hero is
portrayed with very few notable
exceptions they know don't kill off your
villains keep them around let them
continue to do things give them their
full arc we love the villains yeah and
that's one of the things that made
daredevil so cool Wilson Fisk character
kingpin I mean how great was he yeah I
cared little to nothing about the
kingpin character
and the comics at all and then watching
Vincent d'Onofrio's performance I was
like okay I actually give a damn about
the kingpin yeah what else did we like
from this show that we hadn't seen
before
I liked the rated artist I mean the
moral universe has been around the
cinematic universe has been around since
like 2008 now we're getting close to the
10 year mark and I filled it an r-rated
daredevil with the kick in the pants
that it needed I want more of that
Marvel Universe that first season of
daredevil is basically Man Without Fear
that famous Frank Miller story and it
has so many winks and nods to the comic
books gentlemen I'm going to put you on
the spot right now I'm going to ask you
to rank these five shows agents of
shield arrow and then it's really tough
I'm gonna go ahead and I mean just for
me personally I'll put daredevil in then
I'll say flash just becoming awesome I'm
not putting it on the list really don't
care really don't care for Gotham yeah I
mean obviously Gotham okay and then
agents of shield cuz I stopped watching
both of those shows uh-huh and then uh
arrow but could possibly move up
daredevil and then for me the flash is
number one well though my list is
exactly the same as his cuz we're best
friends yeah that's your best friend
that's what Superman so quickly with the
exception of Gotham line was the exact
same as well so we're all to go yeah
Mary oh love me back
you know what this list is definitive
how would you rank them let us know in
the comments section below
the best list with an explanation of how
you arrived at those thoughts we're
gonna send you a screen junkies t-shirt
I want to thank this delightful panel of
gentlemen Jason Inman Kyle Anderson
Jason Wayne Christian thanks for the fun
talk once again I want to thank our
sponsor RetailMeNot text screen junkies
242 767 or click the link on the screen
to download the free app to get awesome
deals to great stores right on your
phone I want to thank you for watching
I'm Hal redneck hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye like do a real Superman movie
yeah Clark is at work in the
the man liked also that'd be pretty cool
because we haven't seen those characters
on film before we haven't even seen
brain eeeh